major-general Qasem Soleimani killed in
a US drone strike on January 3rd was
commander of a clandestine arm of the
Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps known
as the coots force Salim Annie was
plotting imminent and sinister attacks
on American diplomats and military
personnel but we caught him in the act
and terminated him the Koontz force is
in charge of the IRGC x' international
activities and specializes in guerrilla
warfare and armed insurgency the killing
of general Soleimani marks a major
escalation and the US has conflict with
Iran but the u.s. is history with the
coots force goes all the way back to the
Iranian Revolution experts say Iran has
used it to gain influence beyond its
borders deter enemies from attacking
Iran itself and disrupt the efforts of
America and its allies in the Middle
East so the Kurds force is the arm of
the Islamic Revolutionary Guards Corps
of Iran that is charged with exporting
the revolution could means Jerusalem and
they want to see their banners flying
over Jerusalem and so the code's force
being the external operations arm takes
that as its name and as it's in
principle objective the goods force
doesn't have combat units of its own it
doesn't put brigades or divisions on the
ground it works to Train to raise
recruit and train and equip and then
lead proxies who do most of the fighting
the Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps or
IRGC was established after the Iranian
Revolution in 1979 as a force to defend
Iran against internal and external
threats
experts say the coots force was later
formed during or after the iran-iraq war
as the country's de facto External
Affairs branch in the 1980s the IRGC
deployed forces abroad to cultivate one
of its first allied militias the
Lebanese Shia movement Hezbollah
Hezbollah then known as the Islamic
Jihad organization took credit for the
1983 and 1984 bombings of the US Embassy
and Marine Barracks in
root in 2019 US Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo announced sanctions against a
Hezbollah operative accused of carrying
out a 1994 bombing in Argentina in 2015
another Hezbollah operative was arrested
for a 1996 bombing that killed US troops
in Saudi Arabia in 1997 or 1998
iran-iraq war veteran Qasem Soleimani
became the commander of the Kurds force
after the u.s. invaded Iraq in 2003
sulemani built up opposition forces in
Iraq and across the Middle East by
training and arming militia groups the
most notorious thing that the Kurds
force did in Iraq was to provide their
Iraqi proxies with a new type of
anti-tank weapon called an explosively
formed penetrator or EFP and with that
device among other things that could
force is responsible for killing
hundreds of American servicemen and
women in Iraq and wounding thousands the
Trump administration said that
iran-backed militias were responsible
for the deaths of six hundred and eight
US troops in Iraq between 2003 and 2011
we understood that they were recruiting
training and equipping the Shia militias
in Iraq but we chose to fight them in
Iraq and we chose not to take the war to
Iran itself instead the u.s. issued
sanctions against Cootes Force leaders
including a general Soleimani the Trump
administration declared the IRGC a
terrorist organization in 2019 after the
u.s. carried out airstrikes against
iranian-backed militias in Iraq and
Syria
supporters of an Iran back militia tried
to storm the US Embassy in Baghdad this
culminated with the strike against
general Soleimani On January 3rd 2020
the attack on general Soleimani wasn't
just strategic but symbolic as well
Qasem Soleimani was a unique figure he
was at the center of many of the most
important relationships that the Kurds
force had with its proxies there was a
real cult of personality that was built
around him not just in the cruise force
on the IRGC but in Iran
and among Shia in the region he has been
replaced by his deputy as Malkani
who does not have anything like that
charisma certainly does not have
anything like that name recognition the
biggest question going forward might be
how effectively the new Coons Force
Commander connects with the militia
commanders general Soleimani had
cultivated in the Middle East the
organization is not going to collapse
but it will change it will it they will
there will be a period of adjustment
here where they figure out how the world
is going to run for them without Qasem
Soleimani to run